herzlich willkommen bei bild live zurück
mit dieser meldung nämlich panzern für
die ukraine dafür hat die
bundesregierung jetzt gerade grünes
licht gegeben panzer genauer gesagt gepa
panzer aus beständen der industrie für
die ukraine die können jetzt geliefert
werden die hatte die ukraine direkt beim
rüstungshersteller krauss-maffei wegmann
bestellt und die bundesregierung muss
für solche deals eben grünes licht geben
das genau ist jetzt passiert an einem
tag an dem wir auf einen waffen gipfel
schauen der heute auf der us
militärbasis in ramstein stattfindet
dazu passt also diese meldung die gerade
rein gekommen ist